works his way down the boards tied up by gagoski
Tran plays back to the line was on a long shot
and it's covered by Guston interesting start
to the game Andrew Bernett who has to announce
first with his players on the ice and they score
a long shot from the line is deflected may have
been a high stick the officials will discuss and
take a look at it yeah and this is the play right
here it's it's got to be underneath the crossbar
McCarren is CR no question about that one right
there I don't think they were going to look at
this one here very long but something to think
about here here's the ruling after a video
look after video review the call in the ice
is confirmed no goal the puck was struck with a
high stick above the his first two line rotations
were his third and fourth lines Baldi with a shot
perhaps trying to force John hein's hand to say or
it took him a little bit a while to get them into
the rotation Rossy dumps it in from Center for
Minnesota Rossi fights for the loose Puck Novak
knocks it into the corner goes between the legs
for zukar back up high gagoski B Goan winds and
fires and that's deflected wide Rossi dumped at
the side of the net oh trennan controls gives to
Gan to Shen for a shot that deflects wide nearly
two-minute shifts for four of the five Wild
players on the ice right now and guson passes
on the chance to get a whistle a wrap on try goes
right through the crease sends it across to mmis
and here comes Middleton to Center tries to fight
by a check good R fires and a kick save by Soros
opportunity that Freddy G just had 30 seconds
ago might have been the best opportunity the
game between both teams O'Reilly throws one off
the pad of Guston and he lost it to Baldi Baldi
plays ahead to ericon and the wild hits Center
three on three ericon dumps it in Saros plays
it into the corner and it deflects ahead for
forsberg forsberg for O'Reilly at the Minnesota
line gives to Yosi back to nist the shot kicked
Away by guson alosi defending trennan puff comes
out to the line sens a long shot gson doesn't
want to face off and drops it at the side of
the net has it poked Away by Smith nist carries
in night Quist centers O'Reilly to the backand
and a save by gustofson Evangelista spins away
from his check out to the line Fabro yosia Drive
save Guston Novak tried to tuck it in on the
rebound and mosan with a strong play able to
knock the puck against the end boards Philip
gson with a big save keeping this game even
0 if you're on the bench you're talking about
him him not being able to swallow that pocket
Rossi back to capriso he fires saved by Soros
it look like Saros was confident where he had
the puck but he did in fact have it Frozen
the game remains even z0 after sorrow stops
capriso back for Baldi his pass for capriso
deflected But Eric s able to recover BDI with
it again Works to the middle a shot and a save
by Soros opportunity here he just is able to
dance the defenseman mdna to get the inside ice
and Erics 22 left in the power play as gagoski
starts out from behind his neet the Seas part
and he carries in he has Rossi with him and he
fires rebound kicked out by Soros Rossi digging
away and Soros is able to get the whistle where's
everyone going okay I'll take this nice and I
love how he gets the puck on net and then tries
to follow up that's the key right there nice
play there by go goosi and again not handling
the puck clean Soros Novak still with it poke
checked Away by ban Novak to McDonna shot and
a save by guson zuk Carell back to Faber COV
all the way across zarell moves in Centered
for Baldi and a kick save by Soros zukar cut
off by Yosi remember mcdunn one of their better
penalty killers in The Penalty Box Faber across
to zukar moves in back to Capri off a shot he
[Applause] scores Eric s being tipped it on
the way it's a power play goal in the wild
hand the lead few times this time he changes it
up hangs on a little bit more gets the puck out
front there to Krill cof and yes this Puck
definitely gets redirected right off of the
shaft of the stick by Eric Sak and slides
by UC SOS and or right off the [__] pad
it looked like it caught it off the uh the Sha
but that definitely hit a shin pad on the way
in Fred's just starting a trip they
have two stops left they'll go to
Edmonton and Ottawa before
they head into their break
trennan across Carri a in and he
scores carrier beats gustaffson over the stick
side shoulder and Nashville has tied it 1-1
jumping up into the Rush Plays with uh Roman Yosi
here and just is able to slide on the backside
miscommunication coming into the zone and just an
absolute laser beam up over the blocker you got
a great look right here I think Gus thought for
sure he was shooting glove side able to roll his
wrist over and beats guson Fabro a shot blocked
by Felino nist had his shot go off Escape Yosi
with a long shot that sails wide Fabro got it
through to O'Reilly out to the line they score
Yosi with a shot it was tipped on the way and
it's 2-1 Nashville the Predators scored twice
in the blink of an eye here early in the third
getting the pocket to the top here to Roman Yosi
who's got an absolute bomb and I don't know if
that one was redirected on its way in here's the
shot right here yeah it is slightly deflected like
carier got a piece of that one and O'Reilly lugs
it back the other way veteran centerman Cup
winner in St Louis hands it off in the corner
to Nyquist back to yosia shot and they score it
changed Direction on the way and Guston fooled by
it it's 3-1 Nashville Zone and their Top Line who
scored the second goal throw the puck here on the
net it looks like it catches a part of Faber as
this Puck comes in here Roman Yosi able to get the
puck pass Capri off right here yeah gets caught
up in Brock Faber's Jersey flutters through his
jersey lot of game but he got pulled in that
game so you knew he was going to bounce back
faab couldn't handle it cleanly it's a chance
for Nashville Evangelista with a redirect and
Guston makes a save apart to take a 3-1 lead or
2-1 lead early in the period Then they stretched
it to three almost made it back to favor off the
boards not out of the Zone Gus still doesn't have
his stick Evangelista cuts to the slot a shot
and a pad saved by gustofson [Applause] Baldi
out to Faber zuk Carell fire save Soros rebound
loose in the circle side that may have played a
role right there wild are able to come up with
that [Applause] puck D stays put Baldi in he
[Music] [Applause]
scores and the power play goal has Minnesota
back within one don't go anywhere folks was able
to walk inside and he danced the same player MCD
this time he gets inside and he beats yussi Soros
on the far side earlier in the first period
SOS was able to get a Blocker on it not this
time Wild win it again but this time zuk gell has
to work down the wall his
shots blocked and cleared